le 16 septembre dernier à Téhéran une
étudiante âgée de 22 ans Massa mini
Mouret après avoir été arrêté par la
police des mers iraniennes pour un port
de vêtements jugé inapproprié depuis la
révolte s'est installée en Iran révolte
des femmes mais aussi des hommes et des
jeunes qui la soutiennent faisant
jusqu'ici plusieurs centaines de morts
dans le pays cette contestation d'une
ampleur inédite interview moment où la
République islamique d'Iran n'a jamais
semblé aussi puissante à l'extérieur de
ses frontières c'était en tout cas
l'analyse livrée à l'instant dans ce
documentaire réalisé par Vincent de
cointey faut-il voir un paradoxe c'est
jusqu'où ira le soulèvement populaire
qui ébranle de nouveau le régime iranien
nous allons en débattre maintenant avec
nos invités présents sur ce plateau de
débat doc aujourd'hui avec vous pour
commencer à Madame mustaphavi bienvenue
à vous vous êtes franco-iranienne
directrice adjoint de la rédaction de
L'Express en charge du développement
éditorial numérique et puis Delphine
minou est également avec nous bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste franco-uranium
vous aussi spécialiste du monde iranien
vous avez été lauréate du Prix Albert
Londres c'est un prix mythique dans
notre profession qui est le journaliste
c'était en 2006 pour vous reportages à
la fois en Irak et en Iran justement
vous êtes aujourd'hui correspondante
pour le quotidien Le Figaro à
Istanbul et l'on vous doit entre autres
cet ouvrage je vous écris de Téhéran
publié au Seuil ou vous raconter vos
années iraniennes c'était entre
1997 et 2009 première question
évidemment deux mois maintenant après la
mort de cette jeune iranienne d'origine
kurde
Massa Amini elle avait 22 ans où en
est-on de cette contestation en Iran que
peut-on en dire on peut dire déjà que la
contestation est toujours là ce qui est
quand même significatif
je regarde du fait que ça fait deux mois
que les gens s'expriment dans la rue par
des petits actes par des grands actes
des petites manifestations des petits
rassemblements des on les a tous vu des
centaines de vidéos sur les réseaux
sociaux tes actes de courage quand même
quotidien qu'il faut qu'il faut saluer
parce que ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
comme être ici vraiment il faut
s'imaginer que à chaque fois qu'on fait
un acte de désobéissance civile un tag
dans la rue voilà un moment de de ces
jeunes femmes qu'on voit se dévoiler les
écolières qui qui jettent leur voile
tous ces actes sont des actes
potentiellement passifs d'arrestation de
de danger de mort il y a eu ce week-end
de prison des peines de prison ou même
la peine de mort il y a eu un
manifestant qui vient d'être c'est le
premier manifestant qui vient d'être
condamné à la peine de mort pour avoir
participé à des manifestations donc on
est on est face à un régime qui n'a pas
du tout
choisi la voix en tout cas du dialogue
de manifestants du moins qu'on puisse
dire qui est vraiment dans la répression
la plus importante et malgré ça on a
quand même des manifestations qui
continuent depuis deux mois et c'est on
peut donc parler du contestation
aujourd'hui qui reste vivace et qui n'a
pas baissé d'intensité oui c'est
vraiment frappant et c'est à ce
niveau-là que c'est un mouvement
vraiment inédit comparé à ce qui a pu se
passer par le passé en Iran là cette
fois-ci déjà ce qui est très marquant
c'est que les femmes sont sur le devant
de la scène vous avez également un pays
qui bouge du nord au sud
des grandes zones urbaines aux provinces
reculées vous avez toutes les ethnies
côte à côte les Kurdes les baluches
c'est vraiment sans précédent dans
l'histoire de l'Iran et le troisième
élément qui est vraiment très très
marquant c'est que à l'inverse des
mouvements précédents et des des
poussées de fièvre qui ont déjà eu lieu
dans l'Iran de ces dernières années
c'est que aujourd'hui c'est le système
dans son intégralité qui est remise en
ces dernières années il y avait toujours
cette volonté de réformer
l'Iran de l'intérieur et là tout le
monde sort dans la rue en disant la
République islamique c'est fini et un
des slogans phares au-delà du slogan
qu'on a entendu femme vie liberté c'est
mort au dictateur mort à la République
islamique Delphine nous le rappelait à
l'instant décontestation il y en a eu
d'autres beaucoup d'autres revenons
simplement à 2009 le Mouvement Vert donc
il est évidemment question dans le
documentaire que nous on doit il y a eu
aussi les contestations de 2018 le
soulèvement de 2019 vous êtes d'accord
avec l'analyse qui vient dans des fêtes
de 7 contestation actuelle elle est
d'une ampleur jamais constatée jusque là
dans le pays pour les raisons qui
viennent d'être évoquées en partie pour
ces raisons là déjà parce que le fait
est que cette contestation là pour la
première fois s'attaque à la base même
si maintenant les beaucoup plus large à
la question du voile tu vois l'islamique
du voile obligatoire le voile
obligatoire pourquoi c'est si important
parce que c'est vraiment un des piliers
du régime aujourd'hui Islam en Iran ce
n'est pas on a un peu tendance à penser
s'il y a plus de voile il y a plus de
fondement vraiment islamique à ce régime
donc c'est pour ça que c'est si
significatif c'est le fait qu'à la base
c'était ça la première demande que ce
soit aussi les femmes qui sont en
première ligne que ce soit les femmes et
les hommes unis sur les mêmes demandes
que ce soit les différentes générations
aussi il y a une question
générationnelle très forte dans ce
mouvement donc c'est ça ce sont les
choses qui diffèrent mais il faut se
dire que en 2009 quelque part les
manifestants s'adressaient encore au
pouvoir comme si le en demandant où est
mon vote ils avaient un peu en dans
l'idée de se dire on peut encore
dialoguer en fait avec nos dirigeants il
y a eu il y a eu une erreur mais on peut
peut-être dialoguer c'était pas du tout
le cas aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il veut
même plus ils veulent plus entendre
parler c'est la génération Tik Tok la
génération Instagram vous l'appellerez
comme vous voulez mais ces jeunes qui
ont entre 16 et 25 ans pour certains
d'entrevoir plus jeunes même mais aussi
les générations plus âgées qui pourtant
on a affaire des manifestants qui ne
croient plus en une réforme possible du
régime comme vous venez comme ça a été
dit tout à l'heure c'est ça c'est-à-dire
que en fait pendant longtemps et compris
nous journalistes quand on suivait
l'actualité iranienne il y avait cette
idée qui avait voilà des religieux qui
étaient plus modérées que d'autres que
finalement
il y avait aussi ce jeu un peu avec
l'Occident de mettre en avant des
personnages qui parfois avaient l'air
plus ouvert au dialogue en se disant
voilà ça va un peu desserrer la
situation on l'a vu dans le documentaire
aussi que il y a le moment de l'accord
sur le nucléaire avec le ministre des
Affaires étrangères moi-même j'avais
Zarif qui est un personnage avenant qui
est un personnage avec qui on a
l'impression qu'on peut dialoguer
avancer bon tout ça c'est des choses
auxquelles ils iraniens aujourd'hui ne
croient plus du tout donc c'est sûr que
il y a ce sentiment que tel que la
Constitution est écrite et telle que le
régime est fait ce n'est pas fait pour
ce sont vraiment le pouvoir des
religieux c'est
système politique qui est basé sur le
pouvoir des religieux donc
religieux sur le politique aujourd'hui
les gens ça veut pas dire que les gens
ne veulent pas de la religion dans le
cadre privé c'est deux choses
différentes c'est vraiment c'est juste
ils veulent quelque chose ils ont droit
aussi à la démocratie elle a la laïcité
comme comme nous c'est la revanche des
femmes cette révolte je dis ça parce que
quelques mois après la révolution de 79
c'est là que les femmes iraniennes ont
été ramenées à des citoyennes de deux
aimants de deuxième zone avec justement
le chat d'or qui leur était qu'il aurait
été imposé après le régime du chat qui
lui n'imposait pas ce chat dort et qui
avait même fait en sorte à travers je
crois la révolution blanche que les
femmes trouvent toute leur place dans
cette société iranienne il faut y voir
une forme de revanche des femmes
iraniennes aujourd'hui dans cette
contestation oui en 1979 quand les
religieux ont pris le pouvoir tout d'un
coup les femmes se sont retrouvées comme
des citoyennes de seconde catégorie au
regard de la loi islamique donc la
chariaque a été appliquée à ce moment-là
la femme ne valait plus que la moitié
d'un homme elle ne pouvait
présenter son témoignage au tribunal
mais elle n'était que la moitié d'un
homme quand elle se présentait de même
pour l'héritage les femmes n'ont plus à
accès à certains métiers comme celui de
juge les femmes n'ont plus eu le droit
de de chanter de danser d'aller assister
à des matchs de football et le symbole
ultime ça a été le foulard qui a été
imposé généralisé à toute la société
féminine et en fait finalement le combat
des femmes iraniennes il a commencé il y
a 43 ans il a commencé le jour où le
régime a dit vous retournez derrière les
murs de vos maisons et vous vous
enfermez derrière les grillages de vos
voiles et en fait aujourd'hui finalement
ce qui s'est passé avec la mort de Massa
aminis a été l'étincelle qui a déclenché
cette fronde incroyable à laquelle on
assiste aujourd'hui ou des femmes vont
jusqu'à brûler leur voile dans la rue
l'arracher se couper les cheveux en
public
mais ce n'est que finalement la partie
visible de toute cette révolution
discrète invisible qui a été initié je
dirais il y a 43 ans parce que toutes
ces années les femmes elles se elles ont
tout fait pour continuer à se mobiliser
on leur fermer la porte à double tour
elle essayait de rentrer par la petite
fenêtre elles ont créé des ONG des
journaux des magazines elles ont milité
parfois ils ont organisé des sittines
devant le Parlement elles ont participé
à la journée des femmes elles ont été
ultra actives pour tenter
[Musique]
ce qui aspirait à plus de liberté déjà
si on va le rappeler faut monter depuis
en partie depuis la France puisque à
l'époque communie était hébergé ici en
France c'était sous Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing avant de regagner Téhéran et
pour cette fameuse révolution islamique
de 709 on va voir un extrait du
documentaire et ça nous ramène à la
Révolution la contestation de 2009 dont
vous parliez tout à l'heure
suite à la réélection très contestable
de l'ultra conservateur Mahmoud Armani
nedjad à la présidence de la République
en juin 2009 le peuple exige
l'annulation du scrutin la République
islamique vacille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais le guide maintient Armani et Jade
dans ses fonctions et réprime la
contestation avec une violence inouïe
[Applaudissements]
images de violence nous sommes en 2009
le Mouvement Vert et j'ai choisi de
prendre cet extrait parce
qu'effectivement
ce mouvement a fait l'objet d'une
répression très forte très intense et
très violente de la part du régime
évidemment la question qui tombe sous le
sens et de savoir si la révolte actuelle
c'est laquelle on assiste sous nos yeux
va pas connaître le même sort avec une
répression sans limite de la part du
régime
on a on a déjà 304 morts de
comptabiliser donc 41 enfants et 24
femmes selon
eran human right tout à fait et 2000
personnes qui ont été arrêtés inculpées
enfin voilà il y a
les chiffres sont impressionnants
certaines ONG parlent aussi de 15000
personnes qui auraient pu être arrêté
c'est à l'ampleur aussi de la de la
force de la contestation
et la force de la répression oui la
force de la répression c'est vrai que
c'est aujourd'hui le la question c'est
que les forces de sécurité en Iran
ne sont pas du côté des manifestants
voilà clairement il y a une répression
qui est forte qui est faite à la fois
par ce qu'on appelle en Iran les
bassidji qui sont une sorte de milice
populaire je sais pas vraiment comment
le décrire de
militaire voilà
civil enfin voilà c'est pour dire que
c'est pas c'est pas la police ou l'armée
c'est c'est vraiment une une milice du
quotidien qui est là et qui qui s'occupe
de la répression on allait Gardiens de
la révolution qui est l'organisation par
militaire qui est en fait d'armée
parallèles vraiment lié à l'idéologie du
régime
et ce sont ces gens-là qui qui
répliquent qui répriment a priori plus
que l'armée il n'est pas l'armée
régulière avec les chars dans la rue
faut pas imaginer ça mais c'est en tout
cas une répression très forte et très
intense
[Musique]
également en 2017 en 2019 et empire ce
que tout le monde craint il y a un
système de la terreur qui est en train
de se mettre en place vous avez des des
dissidents ou des activistes qui sont
traquées jusque chez eux des étudiants
qui sont tirés de leur dortoir en pleine
nuit vous avez aussi des journalistes
euh qui on fait partie des des premiers
reporters à révéler l'histoire de Massa
Amini qui ont été arrêtés qui sont
derrière les barreaux qui sont accusés
d'être des agents à la solde de la CIA
et quand on entend ses propos venant du
régime on craint le pire on craint de
vivre condamnation il y a des procès en
série qui essaient de s'organiser dans
dans les tribunaux des jeunes qui sont
accusés d'être des Mohame ça veut dire
les ennemis de Dieu et dans ce cas ils
sont passibles de la peine de mort donc
tout ceci est très très inquiétant ce
qui est d'autant plus inquiétant c'est
que il y a une violence assumée de la
part du système qui va jusqu'à attaquer
des mineurs vous avez des jeunes
lycéennes très courageuses qui font des
doigts d'honneur au portrait du Guide
suprême layatollah ramenaille en plein
dans leur dans leur au milieu de leur
classe qui qui piétinent les portraits
qui les déchirent mais qui se font
dénoncer par par les proviseurs par les
enseignants il y a des filles qui ont
été tuées dans ce cadre là d'autres qui
ont été à ce jour vous avez entre 40 et
50 enfants qui sont détenus dans les
prisons iraniennes et tout ceci
évidemment est très inquiétant vu vu
cette force de répression ce qui est
marquant en face en revanche c'est que
la rue ne faiblit pas et que les gens
malgré tout et c'est ce qui nous disent
quand on leur parle au téléphone ces
jeunes manifestants ils nous disent non
on marche vers la mort et on est prêt à
aller jusqu'au bout on a plus rien à
perdre on sent même je pense je trouve
par rapport au début du mouvement au
début du mouvement c'est vrai que bon il
y a eu un peu des excuses sur la façon
dont masala mini avait été traité en
disant voilà une enquête était ouverte
il y a eu un peu une volonté de se dire
on va essayer de quand même dialoguer de
le régime c'est dit bon bien constaté
que il y avait une colère et à essayer
de cantonner cette colère en se disant
voilà c'est un cas précis mais en fait
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est que ça a
tellement dépassé la revue la
revendication d'origine qui était la
mort de ma famille
beaucoup d'autres morts qui à chaque
fois déclenchent une nouvelle colère
face à ça c'est vrai que le régime c'est
encore plus durci et
finalement essaye de de faire douter
j'imagine les manifestants en qui
doivent à chaque fois se demander bon
est-ce que ça vaut la peine vu que
ça va être réprimé très durement
ça en tout cas ça n'a pas l'air de
décourager
découragé la population allez ramenaille
évidemment le guide suprême il est en
place depuis 89 depuis la mort de
comédie il est dit à la fin de ce
documentaire que compte tenu de son
vieillage il a 83 ans aujourd'hui
certains pourraient être tentés de
l'écarter du pouvoir demain et c'est
certain ce sont les gardiens de la
révolution alors les Gardiens de la
révolution c'est un état dans l'état
c'est beaucoup de corruption et dues
d'ailleurs à ce fameux gardien de la
révolution mais enfin ils ont la mamie
sur une grande partie de l'économie du
pays sur une grande partie du système
sécurité vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
est-ce que les Gardiens de la Révolution
peuvent décider demain
de renverser ramenaille
alors profit on s'en est rendu compte au
fil des dernières années je pense que ça
a été très marquant à partir de la
grande répression de 2009 j'étais
moi-même sur place dans les
manifestations à l'époque et je me
souviens c'était l'époque où on voyait
de plus en plus des représentants des
Gardiens de la Révolution venir sur les
plateaux télé de la télévision d'État il
parlait à visage découvert comme si il
tenait les leviers du régime ce régime
qui est devenu une sorte de monstre de
tête avec d'un côté le leader suprême et
de l'autre cette force pretorienne du
régime on sent qu'il y a une
revendication de pouvoir de plus en plus
affirmé comme vous le disiez il détienne
certains leviers économiques c'est eux
qui ont le contrôle des frontières c'est
eux qui ont la main haute aussi sur le
nucléaire il est dit qu'il détiendrait à
peu près 40% de l'économie du pays et
une des suppositions en effet dans les
cercles de discussion à l'heure actuelle
c'est de se dire que si à un moment
donné on se rend compte que le régime
vacille ou si par hasard le guide
suprême meurt il faut savoir qu'il a un
cancer de la prostate il est âgé comme
vous le disiez la 83 ans il n'est pas
exclu que les Gardiens de la Révolution
organisent une sorte de coup d'état et
reprenne en main le régime c'est un
scénario auquel vous croyez vous aussi
ça ce qui est certain c'est qu'il y a
pas non plus de successeur au Guide
suprême qui soit
naturel on va dire y compris dans
l'ordre religieux récemment il a donné
des crédits religieux à son fils
lui-même
un fils à lire aménaï pour bon essayer
de de créer un peu une succession
artificielle mais c'est vrai qu'il n'y a
pas de figure forcément qui se détache
il y en a certains qu'on pensait pouvoir
un jour succéder au guide mais qui sont
morts entre-temps donc il a quand même
une certaine longévité donc oui c'est
vrai que c'est une c'est la force la
plus organisée c'est une force
extrêmement corrompue qui détient
énormément de leviers du pouvoir et qui
sait tout fonctionne de l'Intérieur donc
c'est vrai que si le pouvoir religieux
venait à s'effondrer on peut on peut
craindre que directement ce soit un sort
d'autocratie militaire on va dire qui
prennent la place j'ai vu quelque part
en préparant de cette émission que
certains disent aujourd'hui si les
Gardiens de la Révolution demain
autorisait d'enlever le chat d'or pour
les pour les femmes
auto-zélal et l'ouverture des boîtes de
nuit il pourrait garder le pouvoir
encore 10 ans à la tête de cette
République islamique d'Iran avec cette
formule il croit au profit pas au
Prophète les Gardiens de la Révolution
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez alors
peut-être qu'il pourrait essayer
d'envisager cette possibilité là pour
créer une espèce de semblant d'ouverture
un peu à la chinoise ou je dirais à la
pakistanaise mais dans l'état actuels
des choses il me semble que vu
les revendications de la rue aujourd'hui
les jeunes notamment ne seront pas prêts
à faire ce genre de conc parce que les
jeunes c'est pas seulement les
restrictions religieuses qu'il remettent
en question ce qu'il remettent en
question c'est un régime autocratique
voire dictatoriale qui les empêche de
respirer qui les empêchent de vivre
aujourd'hui ce que nous disent les
filles et les garçons c'est je
revendique la réappropriation de mon
droit à gérer ma vie en tant que telle à
gérer mon corps à vivre comme tous les
autres jeunes du monde entier donc même
si les Gardiens de la Révolution
prennent le pouvoir je pense que ce
mouvement il continuera malgré tout à à
s'exprimer par différents moyens c'est
peut-être l'illustration du fameux
slogan femme vit liberté bien sûr qui a
été scandé dans les cortèges à
l'occasion de cette contestation vous
voulez rajouter quelque chose les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui les jeunes enfin les
jeunes Iraniens il faut bien se rendre
compte qu'ils ont pas grand chose
finalement de différents avec les jeunes
occidentaux dans le sens de leur
ouverture sur le monde si aujourd'hui on
a beaucoup parlé des réseaux sociaux
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que les
Iraniens ont toujours été les jeunes
Iraniens ont toujours été en pointe
depuis que internet existe c'était les
premiers à avoir des blogs à l'époque on
appelait ça là il y a 20 ans la
génération blog en Iran ils ont ils sont
doués en technique entre guillemets ils
savent contourner les sanctions ça fait
des années que les Facebook et Instagram
sont coupés régulièrement mais ils
trouvent toujours des solutions donc
c'est vrai que ce sont des jeunes du
coup très ouvert sur le monde très
éduqué il y a énormément il y a
énormément de femmes notamment de jeunes
filles qui vont des proportions
importantes qui vont à l'université
c'est un pays jeune avec un avec une
proportion de la population qui a moins
de 35 ans qui est très élevé donc
même si l'appareil comment dire
institutionnel pour l'instant ne reflète
pas leurs aspirations ça reste en termes
de masse la force la plus importante
dans le pays donc on peut penser qu'au
bout d'un moment ils obtiendront rien de
cause et ce qui est une forme
d'alternative politique
dans ce pays potentiellement
l'alternative je pense qu'elle est avant
tout du côté de la société civile qui
est impressionnante qui est en effet
peut paraître désorganisé parce que
c'est un mouvement sans leader c'est un
mouvement
horizontale il y a pas de figure qui
émergent enfin en tout cas pas pour
l'instant puisque comme nous le disent
les Iraniens aussi les les figures les
plus symboliques et les plus les plus
actifs sont malheureusement derrière les
barreaux tout le monde
en Algérie aucune figure
ne ressortait du mouvement ou beaucoup
trop de figures peut-être c'est ce qui
se passe c'est que les les opposants
comme les défenseurs des droits de
l'homme comme les plus grands
journalistes comme les plus grands
avocats et avocats je pense à nassrine
soutudé une grande avocate iranienne
tous ces gens là aujourd'hui sont
derrière les barreaux on les amuse les
mais si demain on ouvre les portes des
vignes quelqu'un me disait ça l'autre
jour sous le forme sous d'une blague et
bien nous avons déjà tout le futur
gouvernement iranien rassemblé et les
Iraniens le répète souvent ils disent à
la limite on a même pas besoin de
l'opposition à l'étranger pour créer une
alternative à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et puis il faut pas oublier
qu'il existe aussi d'autres mouvements
tels que les syndicats même s'ils sont
sous pression mais rappelons qu'il y a
en ce moment des mouvements de grève
dans les raffineries pétrolières chez
les médecins du côté des professeurs
donc ce sont aussi tous ces petits
leviers qui s'organisent pas seulement
dans les grandes villes pas seulement
dans les zones urbaines mais dans les
villages il y a encore un système très
fort de liens de solidarité parmi les
Iraniens donc même au-delà des réseaux
sociaux vous avez des gens qui
s'organisent par quartier qui se font
passer le mot je le vois même à travers
les protestataires aujourd'hui quand les
lignes téléphoniques et les lignes de
l'Internet sont coupées et bien il se
passe le mot en se mettant en se collant
des petits tracts sous les essuie-glaces
en faisant du porte-à-porte en passant
des messages d'un toit à l'autre dans
les immeubles dans une ville donc ils ne
sont pas à court d'idées à court de
ressources récemment j'ai été approché
par le biais de l'Internet par des par
un groupe qui ne veut pas être nommé
pour l'instant par peur d'être réprimé
mais qui planche aujourd'hui aussi sur
une espèce d'alternative de constitution
où il propose de faire tomber le terme
islamique à la République islamique il
propose l'égalité entre les femmes pour
pour un futur gouvernement iranien donc
il y a tout plein de cercles de
réflexion qui se mettent en place
aujourd'hui pour réfléchir à un Iron de
demain on a vu des images de joie dans
ce documentaire et elle remonte à 2015 à
juillet 2015 c'est le fameux accord la
signature de l'accord sur le nucléaire
entre l'Iran et les grandes puissances à
commencer par les grandes puissances
occidentales mais pas seulement il y a
évidemment la Russie
cet accord a été d'effets
unilatéralement par Donald Trump en 2017
au grand dames d'une partie de la
population et puis ça crée une situation
sociale terrible à l'intérieur du pays
40% d'inflation 40% de chômage chez les
jeunes Iraniens 25% dans la population
est-ce qu'il y a-t-il un espoir que cet
accord sur le nucléaire iranien soit une
porte de sortie pour le pouvoir si
jamais par exemple les Iraniens
arrivaient à ramener les Russes autour
de la table pour finaliser un nouvel
accord alors la situation est différente
à 7 ans puisque il y a la situation des
Russes et aussi différente aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt une sorte de nouvelle axe
du mal qui semble se dégager entre avec
Vladimir Poutine et Emmanuel Racing qui
renforce leur coopération notamment en
Ukraine contre l'Ukraine donc on voit
les drones iraniens donc la situation
géopolitique est assez différente et
c'est vrai qu'en 2015 c'est vrai que
c'était une joie pour les un an il faut
pas le il faut pas le parce que
justement il y avait cette aspiration à
l'ouverture à la fois économique et
aussi à l'ouverture avec voilà que ça
voulait dire quoi cet accord ça veut
dire par exemple que des entreprises
françaises revenaient s'installer en
Iran ça voulait dire donc des liens
entre la France et l'Iran des employés
des
usines iraniennes qui étaient en lien
avec des des personnes venues de France
enfin voilà c'était aussi
la levée d'un certain nombre de
sanctions progressives c'est ce qui
était prévu dans l'accord
économique bouffée d'air internationale
d'une certaine manière mais
ça ça a pas eu le temps de fonctionner à
vrai dire
et vous pensez que cet accord n'est plus
du tout à l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui
dans le en fait en texte que l'on
connaît je pense que ça n'aurait pas le
même effet aujourd'hui s'il y avait un
accord sur le nucléaire ça n'aurait pas
cet effet là parce que les demandes
maintenant pris une autre proportion on
arrive à la fin de cette émission
Delphine minuit on a vu un documentaire
qui dit
la République islamique d'Iran n'a
jamais été aussi puissante en dehors de
ces frontières qu'aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'il y a pas un paradoxe à avoir cette
démonstration dans ce documentaire et
voir la situation qui prévaut
aujourd'hui sur le plan interne en Iran
ce qui est frappant c'est que au fil de
ces 43 dernières années le régime de la
République islamique il faut le rappeler
c'est retrouver très très isolé au
sortir de la guerre Iran Irak a réussi à
tisser sa toile dans la région à travers
des leviers d'influence le Liban le
Yémen la Syrie le Hamas en Palestine le
régime a également réussi à se tourner
vers l'Est à créer de nouvelles
alliances je pense à la Russie je pense
à la Chine dans cette doctrine de
lentilles occidentalisation donc cet axe
contre les États-Unis notamment mais
tout ceci montait le nationalisme
une certaine manière c'est ce qu'ils ont
tenté de faire mais justement ils l'ont
fait au détriment de leur propre société
et en fait enfermé dans cette doctrine
enfermée dans cette rhétorique il faut
rappeler que à la sortie de la prière du
vendredi et il y a toujours ses slogans
morts aux États-Unis mort à Israël ils
en ont oublié de s'adresser à leur
propre population et de comprendre leur
population et il y a un fossé de plus en
plus croissant entre ce pouvoir qui se
prétend être fort sur la scène
internationale mais qui de plus en plus
fragile en interne un pouvoir très
vieillissant en décalage total la
moyenne d'âge vous les voyez que ce soit
au Parlement que ce soit dans les
cercles autour de l'ayatollah ramena et
c'est entre 60 et 70 ans face à une
jeunesse aujourd'hui qui est dans la rue
qui a entre 15 et 25 ans donc le fossé
il a jamais été aussi marquant il y a
jamais eu autant d'écart entre un
pouvoir de plus en plus isolé j'ai
l'impression sur la scène interne et une
population qui remet en cause
complètement les acquis de la République
islamique ça sera le mot de la fin
vraiment un grand merci à toutes les
deux vraiment d'être venu nous parler de
cette contestation cette révolte à
laquelle on insiste en ce moment même en
Iran deux mois après le début de la
manifestation aujourd'hui et après ce
documentaire que nous avons pu voir et
qui lui nous décrivait ce qui est
aujourd'hui la force de cette République
islamique d'Iran en dehors de ces
frontières vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter bien
entendu nos invités seront là pour
réagir j'imagine à ce que seront vos
réactions merci à celles masali qui
comme à l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer
cette émission et puis je vous donne
quant à moi rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat doc et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]